is the Marvel's destined to fail before
we get started no I am not a the
Marvel's hater I'm not a Captain Marvel
hater a Brie Larson hater whatever it is
I don't hate on it and I do want the
Marvels to succeed I really do but
unfortunately this movie has a lot going
against it that is not really kind of
its own fault in a way for example the
cast I actually think it's a pretty
phenomenal cast we have Brie Larson mon
villani who people really love as Miss
Marvel Sam Jackson's returning as Nick
Fury Park so Joon is making his MCU
debut who's a kdrama actor that I really
really love we have a new villain coming
in darbin and people are excited to see
Photon You could argue the cast is quite
amazing but there are still people out
there
who don't like Brie Larson we're gonna
go into detail really in that in a bit
but let's first talk about the biggest
problem that this movie has against it
unfortunately
it's the budget this movie according to
Forbes has a budget of over
274.8 million dollars which makes it one
of the biggest budgets for any MCU movie
of all time let me put this in
perspective for you there are only three
other MCU movies that have had a bigger
budget than the Marvels coming in at
number one
Avengers end game obviously as you would
expect at
400 million dollars number two Avengers
Age of Ultron
365 million dollars and number three
Avengers Infinity War 300 million
dollars coming in at number four
is the Marvels with its budget a
whopping
274.8 million dollars just so you know
number five is a tide for Thor 11
Thunder Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
and Captain America Civil War at 250
million dollars and then at number six
is the first Avengers film a 225 million
dollars now why is this a problem why is
this going against the movie well just
to put that in perspective for you the
movie's gonna have to make around 450 to
550 million dollars to break even not
make money but break even and let me
just give you this example Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania made
476 million dollars and I would argue
definitely there was more hype for that
movie than there is for the Marvels now
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 did a
whopping 800 and 45.6 million dollars at
the box office but keep in mind they've
been around since phase two they were
involved in Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers end game and most of the cast
is pretty loved by the entire fandom
plus keep in mind this was supposed to
be the last Guardians of the Galaxy film
with the current cast a lot of people
thought there were going to be a lot of
deaths so there's a lot of intrigue
there a lot of people went to see that
movie because they wanted to win see a
good Guardians of the Galaxy movie
because they haven't let us down yet and
two see how that was actually going to
end that's not really the case for the
Marvels again some people out there
don't really like the cast but we go
back to Ant-Man on the WASP quantumania
with it making a little bit over 470
million dollars with more hype that
brings us to the next problem that the
Marvels unfortunately has against it and
that is promotion for it be hype for it
unfortunately right now
we are in strix the cast
they can't promote this film they're not
promoting this film in fact right now
the only person from the movie who's
really promoting it
is the director and unfortunately she
said some things in some interviews as
of recent that have pissed some people
off we're not going to dive into that
you can find them yourself but the
strikes are going to affect the movie
because the promotions or the lack
thereof are going to affect the movies
in fact industry data analysts suggest
that about 10 to 20 of movies are going
to be affected each movie will be
affected by 10 to 20 because the casts
cannot promote these films and again no
one from the cast right now is promoting
the film now that's going to drastically
affect the movie but we have to talk
about really what defines a success what
would make this movie a success or
failure because it's pretty important to
know what that actually means and we'll
talk about that in just a bit but first
a big thank you to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video many of you may
know that I personally use hellofresh
and I love it it makes cooking fun easy
and it's affordable and that's why it's
America's number one meal kit delivered
straight to your door and you might not
know that they actually have seasonal
recipes right now since it's summer they
have their new fresh and fit summer menu
so if you're trying to get that beach
bud but you're also trying to eat really
great tasting food it's perfect for you
right now it's peak time for summer
produce and hellofresh make sure you get
all the best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than seven days for Quality
you can taste if you are trying to
impress your friends this summer by
doing some cooking for them hellofresh
makes it super simple they give you all
of the ingredients and tell you exactly
how to make each meal and the best part
is right now you can go to
hellofresh.com 50 Cosmic and use code 50
Cosmic for 50 off plus 15 off the next
two months that's hellofresh.com 50
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50 off
plus 15 off the next two months
now what would Define a success for this
movie well as I mentioned the movie
would have to make around 450 to 550
million dollars just to break even and
you would never say a movie that broke
even was a success that's not really how
it works but what number would this
movie have to hit to actually make it a
success well unfortunately it would have
to hit around 600 to 750 million dollars
to be considered a success now Captain
Marvel 1 hit a billion dollars but that
was before the hate started some people
didn't know well really everybody didn't
really know what to expect from the
movie plus you have to take into mind
into consideration that this movie was
before Avengers endgame and you had to
watch this movie going into Avengers
endgame as well plus it was set in the
past so that was even more intriguing
interest for the movie however that is
all gone it doesn't have any of that
going for it right now Captain Marvel 2
or the Marvel doesn't have all that hype
and all that excitement and all that
mystery concerning it going into this
movie it has none of these things
unfortunately plus not to mention
superhero fatigue is a real thing for
some people and unfortunately the last
project that Marvel Studios did a secret
Invasion which kind of bombed but what
is directly tied to secret Invasion
immediately following it up the Marvels
so some people already have a bad taste
in their mouth for this movie
unfortunately and again that's not even
the movie's fault
now there is hope for the movie
fortunately I'm not sure it's all going
to happen a lot of things would have to
fall into place but I do hope the movie
succeeds and here's a few ways how it
could one is the strikes could actually
end we've heard word that negotiations
are going kind of well right now now
we've heard that before all for it to
turn around and just you know fall apart
but right now we've heard word rumors
that things are going pretty well if the
strikes end in the cast could very
quickly and right away start to promote
the film that would definitely help it
and it could probably get rid of that 10
to 20 percent negative effect that the
strike would have on that so that would
be good let's hope the strikes end just
in general pretty soon but also so the
Marvels can be promoted properly the
second thing is
the film could simply be amazing let's
hope and if it is simply amazing then
the Rotten Tomato scores
will be good for it now if they're bad
it's going to really really really
hurt the movie but if they're good it
could do a lot of great things for this
movie and really help it hit those
numbers and one of the last things
that's just kind of a positive that
happened just because of the strikes
actually and everything going on is Dune
was delayed it was going to have to
compete with Dune which would have been
pretty detrimental to it so fortunately
for the Marvels it does not have to
compete with Dune anymore so there is
hope for the movie and go see the movie
for yourself and form your own opinion
about it before you kind of take
everybody's word for it because we know
there are people out there who just hate
Brie Larson in general they just don't
like her for whatever reason hype it is
what it is there are people out there
and they're gonna review vomit they're
gonna do a lot of stuff please form your
own opinion and if you end up not liking
it that's fine that's your opinion and
if you didn't like the first Captain
Marvel film I feel ya it wasn't the
greatest movie of all time it was one of
the lower MCU films I didn't it by any
means but it's kind of just
fine however I am hopeful for the future
I'm hopeful for the Marvels I hope it
does really well again the cast is
pretty phenomenal the characters are
pretty great and I hope this is a
turnaround for the MCU I even hear that
it's going to connect to the larger MCU
in a pretty big way we're gonna see some
incursions is what I heard so there's a
lot of excitement in my mind for the
movie and I hope for a lot of other fans
as well I really hope all of these
things that are going to affect it don't
affect it too bad but unfortunately
I do think right now this movie is
somewhat destined to fail just because
of everything going against it but hey
let me know what you think about it in
the comments down below are you excited
for this movie
no let me know all your thoughts please
let me know what you think is gonna
happen in this movie and also to this
movie what is this performance gonna be
in the box office we don't know
hopefully it's enough to at least break
even maybe it could boost up those
numbers a couple hundred million more to
be considered a success but we'll have
to say in the meantime subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
foreign